bring the kids inside and I need to
think because if I go off impulse yeah
that's scary what you just said is
already scary he's gonna kill the whole
family I'm gonna do something that's not
gonna be beneficial long term it might
be beneficial short term see he's gonna
kill him
[Music]
so first of all
um I'm gonna tell you guys about this
thing that happened but
we need to hear from Bart immediately
after to see if you would do the same
thing oh I'm me don't bias the answer
because I think you're the only a real
dad in the room oh what the [__] dude
that's controversial so check it out
there's a father in Idaho okay he's with
his two young daughters in the in the
backyard
they spot a guy The Neighbor Next Door
at his window jerking it in full view
Jesus Christ so these little girls so
he's got his dick up on the window so
think about this he's got his dick all
the way up on the window so and then and
then it's hitting the window glass the
pain is like vibrating so it doesn't
even feel good for him or it does yeah
so he's doing that looking down there
kids the father files a police report oh
no police
if I was a police report about the
incident
and it's almost like the cops are
ignoring it they no charges are filed or
anything so he gets really upset and he
starts to think that like hey they're
just gonna let this go they're not gonna
do anything about it so what does he do
he grabs his gun breaks into the house
and he wipes out their entire family oh
that's too much whoa he kills that dude
that's too much he kills um he kills the
both parents and another 16 year old son
what wow what if they were all victims
of him being a bad guy that's too much
so really it's too much that's usually
what you guys pitch is for what we
should do
erase this whole bloodline that's too
much I never touched a family no you
don't think so
they should kill his family
second cousins that's not something I
don't think it's the family like that no
no no sorry Rob Zombie get two horses
what would you do you solve that
situation
you know you tie a rope to you know a
guy's Limbs and then you take two horses
and make them run that that's from
[__] wife I've heard you guys say
that uh-huh everybody in this room is so
though yeah Colleen said it once
what's the correct reaction okay if I
saw that I think the first thing I would
do is probably bring the kids inside and
I need to think because if I go off
impulse yeah that's scary as [__] hey
what you just said is already scary
because I can't oh he's gonna kill the
whole family I'm gonna do something
that's not gonna be beneficial long term
it might be beneficial short term see
he's gonna kill the whole thing
that's the whole thing that is so scary
and you just sit and think because I
don't trust myself yeah if I just always
beat the [__] out of them I'm like he's
still my neighbor he's literally my
neighbor you know so I gotta go like
maybe I gotta figure out plans to move
first okay but path of least resistance
I need that no no and then I come back
later but I gotta like because you know
when you want to plan a crime you got to
find the destination and reverse
engineer your way back well because you
don't want to be caught yeah so I don't
want to beat the [__] out of my neighbor
and then my neighbor goes my neighbor
beat the [__] out of me now I go to jail
now he keeps jacking off in front of
Tycoon for the next 20 years right yeah
so I'm like that's that's not smart so
I'm like I need to get out of this
situation first but then I'll always
remember what happened okay and then
I'll figure out how to so I gotta go
think that's my first thing think okay
you could if he's just out in the open
you can just record docs it and then let
the internet have them because they'll
go [__] hard that's one way would my
page just get flagged for [__] having
a guy jacking off yeah and you'd be
flagged for bullying really would that
be bullet I mean like if I can't put
someone else's jacket go put yourself
ghost account yeah but isn't it like
public indecency like what ain't that
yeah that's illegal was he beating it to
like is it he's a guy right he's beating
it right he's beat it to a daughter or
something daughters who has two
daughters okay that's different though
see that's what I gotta think because if
I just jump to my Ig yeah let's say it
does go viral now everyone knows where I
live too not your personal account well
on a boat if it's a ghost one I don't
know if people would actually care like
there's no like what's the stakes
there's like oh he's one of the millions
of people that beat to people people in
labor right right there's a lot of
people that care yeah yeah you post that
[__] like on 4chan or whatever like they
go that's a big deal but wouldn't they
also know that they'll find they'll try
to angulate the location but they also
triangulate me they'll find you from the
type of bush that's growing in your area
yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't want to be I
don't want to be visible so like I would
have to leave first oh because then now
that guy knows that you recorded it so
that now it's like you didn't finish the
job because he's still alive or if
people come in like let's say they want
to like I don't know [__] SWAT this
house or whatever they're gonna be like
oh wait the end goal was from that house
let's go meet that guy and then say hey
man you're a hero and they're gonna come
find out know who I am and I gotta want
too much publicity like that yeah it is
a lot of unwanted activity that's why I
gotta go think before I make a move the
thing is I don't know even no matter
where the [__] I am I don't know who the
D.A is so I'm already there they'll just
arrest me whatever even if this is
[__] Idaho by the way and he didn't
trust the cops now imagine you're in
Portland OR California or some [__] oh
God yeah awful this is Idaho brother
yeah this is like wind polls close the
Republican wins in like two and a half
seconds that's kind of [__] yeah so now
it's like what the [__] is going on in
Idaho so I'm like all right my whole
thing is I would just immediately
um call the call the cops make sure
there's a police report and then I would
just do some [__] about my alarm system
because I don't I'm not gonna assault
this guy and go get sued to hell and
lose my house or some [__] yeah I think
first thing is you gotta get a video of
this dude jerking it yep
that's that's back pocket that's you
figure out what you do with that later
but because even if you don't publicize
it I can blackmail them you got to get
evidence number one yeah evidence just
be like hey man come here and then you
show them the video
you want me to show this to your wife
does she know about this [__] so I think
they I think the family did know so
they're a family of perverts I think so
or he or he's been abusing the whole
family I think that family on the other
side I think they're just trash and I
think he might have confronted them and
said something and they and they were
like defending or something so also
that's why he felt Justified all over in
front of the house anyway they had like
a weird dispute yeah he probably just
has the whole family just has to die
then you know
if we're gonna go that route then the
first thing we do is we go to Home Depot
we buy a bunch of wooden boards I board
up all the windows and doors and then I
start filling the house with cement from
the chimney
[Laughter]
expensive that's really expensive we got
we call [__] cmex or whatever that
company is
murder everybody I'd probably do what
this guy did it's way cheaper five for
one I mean all he did was take his gun
break into the house but then now what
he's in jail now that's the sad part is
like now you're just out of your kid
he's he's facing life in prison [__]
like he's good he's not gonna be in his
child's life yeah that's why I gotta
reverse engineer everything I'm like
Parson bro what's the craziest crime on
the gas line on yeah
do I need to flee the country or like
what the [__] am I gonna do how much is
something but sometimes you got to do it
one two three how much is a matchbook
you get a hose you put in your exhaust
and you put it into the window of the
house and then you just let it run dude
while they're sleeping then they like oh
we see you with the hose [__] 500
feet of Hose
but it's like a real small hose like a
real tiny hose a real tiny hose that
makes sense why you killed the whole
family because he went over to confront
and then they all that does change
things I think they were like a trashy
and it's like oh yeah it's like okay
you're all you're all complicit in this
[__] weird [__] and then you just
went in there and massacred the entire
family oh that's [__] that's pretty
funny that's crazy now your daughter
doesn't or your son doesn't have you
yeah see that's why you can't you can't
be too impulsive yeah that's what I'm
saying it feels good now is not good but
that's so crazy that the cops didn't do
anything that too crazy in Idaho too
yeah right I would imagine they don't
take you know like they take that stuff
very seriously imagine they don't take
kindly
defund the police movement they went
straight to Idaho because they knew that
was like the place where they actually
respect cops the most so this is like
really crazy but even then though if you
think about the technicality right they
call the police and they say this guy's
jacking off
that's it
yeah what are they going to do public
indecency like you know it's like
they're like I'm jacking off what do you
want me to do
so it makes it
the book of police dispatch hey hey this
guy's a cool bladed about jacking off
I'm jacking off hey
hey chief come lock me up too huh as
soon as the rest I'm gonna handcuffed
myself I can still jack off hey uh hey
sorry we're out we're too busy arresting
each other over here for jerking it
gonna be a little busy
a couple of Wise Guys
but that is definitely one of the one of
the uh details is that the father felt
like there was never going to be any
justice for what happened you know
that's actually the number one purpose
of the justice system for us to catch
jerkers no it's two um third party just
it's two third-party prevent vigilantism
yeah for like revenge and stuff so you
have a completely different system that
is supposed to take care of these things
so that we don't have people coming in
killing each other off because it's like
eye for an eye like if we keep doing it
it's gonna be family feuds so the police
wrote the police report and it's the D.A
that didn't want to prosecute or like
it's unclear it just it they just know
that if it was like it got shelled just
did enough nothing yeah well some of
those things are really tricky the
details of him calling the cops and they
it is a file but it just never got acted
on yeah because what can they charge
them on he's in his house I mean he's
he's jerking it towards kids that's
you'd be easy it's exposing yourself to
a minor yeah I thought that was a charge
it's an actual it's illegal yeah you
can't do that it's called jerking
towards kids can't even do it on Omegle
it's a it's a it's a statue that is also
kind of sad when like the crime
doesn't match your emotions it drapes
yeah
but you know what I mean like when
someone's jerking it towards your kids
it's like a [__] visceral response
right yeah but then if someone were to
write it down it's like oh he was just
masturbating in the window in front of
miners then it's like what is that oh
two weeks in jail but like what the [__]
those are my [__] kids though yeah so
it's like
it's like it yeah it doesn't match it's
someone that gets caught with a piece of
crack does like 10 years yeah but a guy
that jacks off in front of kids gets out
in two weeks is towards the
proportionate like it's [__] weird
what's up with the sex offender stuff
then he doesn't get put on a list or
something that's what he wanted he
wanted all these things to happen where
he now he can't live in certain areas
like he wants the the guy to pay what
he's supposed to pay yeah but he's
supposed to be jerking off in the window
like well that's why the justice system
can't fail because if it can't fail then
people feel unjustified yeah so now they
have to go and [__] kill that was a
big uh as we say here
but like at the same time like oh
actually I was gonna say I can't blame
him but no go ahead Lynn we'll end on
that note go ahead Nick says he can't
play you can't blame him for jerking
you're talking about the Joker
this guy that's what Nick says this guy
right that's what Nick Dunn says not the
masturbator he was my friend but he's I
don't I don't really know him very well
you guys saw it you guys saw yourself
Nick was going like this I didn't really
know Nick I I knew him just during JK
shoots so yeah I don't know
[Music]
laughs